Let's take it back to Pakistan, former
president Imran Khan on has been arrested.
Joining us from the capital, the images
really captivating people. The way they
burst into this courthouse, and pulled him out.
>> Yes, max these are very dramatic images that
have come out of Islam. We've seen many many
paramilitary groups, here in Pakistan, they are
not the police. They have apprehended iran khan.
As you see the footage, they came out in droves,
put him in a car, and have driven him off to
national -- bureau. An anti-corruption watchdog,
here in Pakistan. They have been
charges, of corruption against him,
he's making multiple court appearances. He he
drew to Islamabad this morning, to make that court
[8:08:28 AM]
morning, to make that court appearance,
just released, his party has just released a
prerecorded statement from him Ron khan saying the
reason people are watching this video is because
he has been detained. In the video he said that
the reason he has been detained is because, in the
current authorities power, the power that, be they
do not want him to continue his political party.
They do not want him to fight for the fundamental
rights of Pakistan's. They want imran khan,
according to con, to understand and approve of
the current government that is in power. Imran
khan has been ousted, in a vote of no confidence
in April this last year, a consistent state of
political uncertainty here in Pakistan. Iran
confident assassination scare about, against
him last year, accusing the prime minister
as well as senior intelligence officers for
being behind the attack. He is not given much
evidence for, it just last night Pakistan's
military had released a very ominous statement,
saying imran khan was irresponsible in his
[8:09:29 AM]
was irresponsible in his statement, he
should refrain from making such statements,
con had responded again, quite
vehemently to the statement made.
Saying the Pakistani military, the pr for
the Pakistani military, and the official
spokesperson. The people that have arrested khan,
who have apprehended, con are not the police. The
police have tried to arrest con previously,
protests have broken out across the country,
we are just waiting to see what the response
will be as the afternoon goes into the night